this blue marble-like planet looks just
like Earth but only five seconds on this
hostile death orb would kill you
welcome to hd189733b
this planet is enormous even larger than
Jupiter
and to keep comparing it to the largest
planet in our solar system it's also
entirely made of gas
that's why scientists classify
hd189733b as a hot Jupiter this planet
is located so close to its star that it
completes its orbit in just over two
days
yeah
hd189733b is 13 times closer to its Sun
than Mercury is to our sun
and even though its star is cooler than
ours this fake Earth is still way
outside its star system's habitable zone
that means no liquid water can exist on
a planet's surface
just how this giant gaseous Planet
developed so close to a star is still a
mystery one theory is that
hd189733b formed right next to it during
the star's earliest moments or it could
have developed further away only to be
pulled in as the rest of the planetary
system formed
but there's one thing we know for sure
a visit to
hd189733b would be a plunge into hell
with no chance of Escape
now even if you knew there wasn't a
single drop of liquid water on this
planet you'd have a hard time believing
it as you approached the giant blue
marble with an average daytime
temperature of nearly 1100 degrees
Celsius this planet is twice as hot as
Venus and Venus is the hottest planet in
our solar system
one of the reasons for this intense heat
is that the planet is tidally locked to
its star just like our own moon is to
Earth
that means
hd189733b takes as much time to spin on
its axis as it does to revolve around
the star
so one side of the planet is constantly
in daylight while the other side is
shrouded in darkness
the inviting look of this world doesn't
come from its oceans like it does here
on Earth no this hellish Planet gets its
color from clouds of molten silicate
particles
these particles scatter more blue light
than red making the planet appear blue
silica is the primary ingredient in
glass and you should bring a heavy duty
umbrella because you'd need to take
cover from what would essentially be hot
molten glass rainstorms
but that's not the only danger you'd
need to be ready to brace yourself
against the extremely powerful winds
that you'd find sweeping across the
planet
with speeds up to 7 000 kilometers per
hour these gusts are almost 30 times
stronger than even the most powerful
category five hurricanes on Earth
compared to the strongest winds on other
planets in our solar system hd's winds
are almost four times stronger than
those on Neptune but hey they might
smell a little better than the ice
Giant's hydrogen sulfide clouds
those carry a whiff of rotten eggs
[Applause]
hd's winds are so fast that they'd whip
past you at about six times faster than
the speed of sound
they would be extremely loud but I think
you'd be more worried about them tearing
your body apart you might be long gone
by now killed by that molten glass rain
in any case you wouldn't last too long
on
hd189733b I really don't recommend
traveling there
but there are some planets out there
that can kill you even faster
check out oglet TR 56b
this gas giant sits in a galaxy nearly
100 light years away from Earth
it's even larger than HD its mass is
nearly 1.4 times as much as Jupiter's
and somehow it's even closer to its star
too
you'd find this world to be incredibly
scorching hot
surface temperatures on this planet
average around 1700 degrees Celsius
that's so hot that it turns metal to gas
creating iron clouds in the upper
atmosphere
if you got caught in the rain here
find it to be an extremely unpleasant
and deadly shower of hot molten iron
your skin would burn right off and so
would your insides
but things could get even hotter
some 670 light years away from Earth
there's a planet so hellish that it's
tearing molecules apart
meet celt9b
this gas giant is almost three times
more massive than Jupiter it takes kelt
only one and a half Earth days to speed
through the orbit around its Sun
and just like
hd189733b it's tidally locked with one
side always facing the hot star
landing on this planet you'd experience
temperatures as high as 4 300 degrees
Celsius
it's the most scorching exoplanet we've
ever discovered
scientists call this gas giant an ultra
hot Jupiter and those high temperatures
also make celt 9B hotter than most stars
in the universe
so hot that it would destroy you
come on this world rips apart molecular
hydrogen gas what do you think it would
do to your body
but before you even arrive on this hot
planet you'd be exposed to deadly
amounts of radiation coming from its
host Sun
yeah celt 9B receives about 44 000 times
more energy from its star than Earth
does from the Sun
this radiation would cook you alive
instantly
okay if you somehow managed to survive
all the lethal radiation of celt star
and the unimaginable heat of the planet
well you'd still have to take on its
incredibly strong winds
scientists think those winds could reach
speeds of 60 kilometers per second
yeah that's 30 times faster than the
winds on the deceivingly Earth looking
Planet
hd189 733b okay so if I get this
straight kelp 9B would swirl you burn
you and tear your molecules apart
hmm one out of ten would not recommend
if you think meeting your demise on
these kinds of hellish planets could be
fun well I have some better travel
suggestions for you you know not
everything out there in space is utterly
terrifying
there are planets that orbit their stars
at a safe distance just like the Earth
orbits the Sun
we've yet to study those worlds in depth
but some of the exoplanets we've found
so far could be even better for life
than Earth
yeah and you know what that's a story
hey everyone want to tell you about our
next video I'm really excited about it's
a new format where I have to go and
collect all the elements of the periodic
table let's see how far we can get with
just everyday items I think you'll be
surprised what I come up with so
subscribe right now and don't miss it
[Music]